now with the continued record-breaking
numbers all counties in our state
except for story are in the red well a
group met today to go over those numbers
the state's response and much more the
i-teams vanessa
murphy standing by joining us live she
monitored what was a three-hour meeting
and tells us what came out of it vanessa
brian the numbers indicate there is
significant community spread in nevada
what does that mean a person catches the
virus but the source
is unknown they caught it somewhere in
the community but they just
don't know how now as we've been
reporting covet 19 hospitalizations are
up according to the nevada hospital
association they
account for 30 percent of patients in
hospitals right now
hospital staffing is a major issue there
was a nursing shortage
prior to the pandemic and nurses are
needed even more now
a biostatistician with the department of
health and human services stresses how
nevada is hitting record highs on a
daily basis
and at this point we are more than a
week into the governor's three-week
pause
i think it tells the story that that is
driving these decisions at the state
level
and the decisions the difficult
decisions the governor is having to make
the kovit 19 mitigation and management
task force met to examine
several issues including testing the
vaccination plan
and compliance according to the division
of business and industry some
construction companies in southern
nevada are not following the rules
while the gaming control board reports
only two violations for casinos
in the month of november we also heard
from the state superintendent of schools
she is advocating for children to be
back in the classroom
physically back in schools or for
families to at least have a choice
we'll have more on that coming up at 5.
reporting live vanessa murphy
8 news now